l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a che sono
video io sono fa vj oggi la sera di
halloween quindi ho pensato di fare un
qualcosa di speciale per tutti quanti
voi è successo una volta tipo qualche
settimana fa in un blog di fare una
certa cosa che io ho fatto ma nel blog
non l'ho messa perché mi sono accorto
che come cosa era abbastanza paurosa ma
veramente paurosa ragazzi io non lo
aspettavo per niente si tratta di
leggere un fumetto horror praticamente
ragazzi io non non sapevo nulla l'ho
letto diciamo che questa parte qua nel
blog non l'ho messo aspettato che
arrivasse halloween perché volevo
proporvelo come vino non è un video
normale un video che dura poco però
quindi ragazzi ray che possa lasciare al
video ci vediamo tra poco ma vi risponde
fa vitis fino a spegnere la luce di
camera tue leggere questo fumetto in
diretta indiretta
buona fortuna avrai bisogno che va bè
solo perché me lo ha chiesto quel tice è
un'area composta da incazzo di frumento
al buio è che cos'è un clip ipasta mi
metto tranquillo perché è stracchi è
questo ma è in giapponese sta roba no
ancora no agli inglesi perfetto mi stava
trascinando a casa esausta dopo una
sessione di notte studio a scuola non
c'era nessuno per strada il che mi è
sembrato molto strano di solito vedo
molte persone di notte sotto il mio
appartamento perché è molto grande e
comunque mi sentivo molto spaventata
aveva lo sguardo rivolto verso il basso
mentre tornavo a casa poi
improvvisamente un'ombra apparve davanti
ai miei occhi nonostante non avessi
visto nessuno camminare davanti avevo
guardato su e che ho visto era una donna
che cambia
c'è chi è gran [ __ ] i sogni donna che
camminano lo sa perché la mia farina la
tizia bellezze camminata di fronte a me
ma mi ha guardato in modo un po strano
tutto quello che posso dire che sembrava
storpia e quello che potevo notare che
camminava in modo strano davanti a me
indossava un pigiama rosa e sembrava che
tutte le sue articolazioni fossero
devastate e ancor peggio i suoi capelli
erano un ammasso di roba appiccicata
ovunque una visione così strana che ho
smesso di camminare sembrava opportuno
non avvicinarsi troppo a lei quindi
dovevo passare le dica
bocciatura ya basta è mosso con la merda
ma se posso quella merda nuova sei serio
che la [ __ ] del cazzo il pri giorno
ma si è mossa davvero a caso in un
fumetto massa cosa è stata bellino
bellissima una sedia ora che non l'ho
capita sta cosa
ma sti cazzi se sei [ __ ] sono saltato di
bruno sta cosa non me la giura non me
l'aspettavo è bruttissimo congo ancora
da baby che no nonino cosi in basso dopo
e dopo questo bastano continuo piena 6
dov'è il mio bambino non sapevo che cosa
pensare dopo quella domanda
mica è direi ha risposto puntando il
dito più lontano che potessi o volgare e
laggiù è laggiù ok si vabbè ma che cazzo
da indicazioni a una così e in famiglia
mi ha tutto quello che volevo che lei
andasse lontano da me dopo di che lei si
è avviata nel punto dove l'avevo
indicato fantastico e non l'avrei mai
più rivista ray grazie a dio è tanto cia
le converse sta tizia spaventata dal
poterla incontrare di nuovo mi sono
girata e sono andata lontano da dove mi
trovavo non pensando a niente ma
ricercando di trovare un posto dove ci
sarebbero state altre persone al momento
lei non l ho sentito questo urlo da
lontano ma [ __ ] [ __ ] basta
che cazzo è caduto corrotto
dove senza finito il mano bastava bene
grazie di avermi inviato star sta merda
mi sono rotto il conto basta
grazie va bene così e stato bello è
stato molto bello è stato pesante giuro
che è stato pesante quindi ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto allora in teoria non
l'avevo messo perché è uscito abbastanza
lunghetto mi occupava tipo lamenta del
blog quindi l'ho voluto mettere come
speciale di halloween
spero mi piace ragazzi non è è durato
pochissimo ovviamente mal essendo uno
speciale serale così andava bene lo
stesso pero vi sia piaciuto ragazzine
che posso concludere qui tra l'altro la
candela mi si stati pole secondo me
prende fuoco qualcosa prima che finisca
il vino quindi ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto lasciato il commento mi piace
anche a valiani facebook e comodi da
trattare descrizione se non siete ancora
i siti iscrivetevi e state attenti
quando girate per strada perché potresti
incontrare gente il pigiama o forse sono
io che cercavo il frigo vabbè che i
ragazzi ci vediamo un prossimo video
bella tutti è spenta la candela
[ __ ]